today on the anime zone or a view of
wait a minute there's no review today
you mean it's only gonna be one of those
cheesy 1000 subscribers thank you videos
nobody actually cares about even though
I hit a thousand ages ago okay well if
you are my oldest describes and thanks
for sticking around for me so far and I
hope you continue to do so and if you're
one of my new subscribers then all I can
say to you is welcome to the anime zone
I hope you've enjoyed the constructive
fast-paced sarcastic videos are my anime
reviews and for the last [ __ ] time go
with Bako now
oh well call me Susan and bug me
sideways who would have thought after a
year and a half of foul-mouth well
actually don't call me Susan or bug me
sideways that's a bit gay but anyway who
would have thought after year and a half
of foul-mouthed fast-talking badly
written reviews with some blatant ads
ripping off of zero punctuation
wink wink then I today be celebrating
1000 subscribers okay well it's actually
more like 1107 subscribers now since
I've been incredibly late to making this
video but still that's over 1000
subscribers now even though I'm normally
too lazy to do anything to celebrate I
thought to make an exception this one
time and to thank all you guys would get
me over 1,000 subscribers sorry I'll
stop doing that now so to celebrate this
occasion I thought I'd wait what am I
supposed to do in this video should I
talk about what you guys should expect
in the future
well okay if you're wondering what you
can expect from in the future we can
probably expect the same thing you've
always been expecting me sitting on my
lazy ass today me sitting um lazy also
they me sitting on my lazy ass today
while reading comments telling me to get
off my lazy ass and somewhere along the
line when the moon is blue and Lady Gaga
finally admits being a man I'll finally
start making more reviews while sitting
on my lazy ass all day or maybe I'm
supposed to talk about what I've learned
for my tongue YouTube well out of the
many things I've learned people can be
surprisingly patient for you to make
your next video which I'm grateful for
there will always be some utter idiots
on here who already seem to have the
words good and Berk in their vocabulary
and all you need to do to be funny on
the internet is swear moan and [ __ ]
sarcastically in a British accent
because as everyone knows if you're
American you swear a lot that you just
sound like a complete nob end but if
you're British can you swear a lot then
everyone finds it bloody hilarious right
or should I talk about what my next
review will be well if you're wondering
boys can be keep wondering because I
haven't decided myself yet since you
know I've been involved in the
activities of being sluggish and seated
but feel free to request an anime since
despite what you may think I do take
know of every request given to me and at
this moment of time I request this
actually quite small on a second
on a serious matter guys I want to thank
all my subscribers so far everyone has
commented in my videos and I want to
thank I want to be so patient I mean I
know it's been months between reviews
and this fire thing I said I haven't
just been on my lazy ass I have had
real-life [ __ ] to deal with and
University work so you know who doesn't
these days but you guys have been
awesome I mean when I saw this never ate
to get this many subscribers because I
neo would get compared to Yahtzee when I
started this and for my experience
anyone who gets compared to Yahtzee
normally get crucified by his fanboys
and even though I have had a lot of
comments going oh you remind me of your
C cuz you're British and you're speaking
fast and you're revealing [ __ ] you know
I haven't had many negative comments
about it which really surprised me
actually affect more positive comments
about it so thanks for that but I hope
you will continue to enjoy my reviews
and I hope I get to continue making them
before YouTube finally gets on their ass
and start removing my videos which I'm
surprised they haven't yet but hopefully
it'll be a long time before you do so
yeah you guys are awesome so again guys
thanks for all the comments she giving
me positive and negative and thanks for
being so patient with me because like I
said it's not all the laziness this time
and again thanks for the 1000 subs
though at the end of the day if I have
viewers like you guys it doesn't really
matter how many subscribers I have
whether it be one thousand two hundred
to five or three hundred thousand three
hundred thirty six because really there
isn't anything so special about these
numbers except maybe it's all c-3po says
when he ejaculates and I'm feeling
right